mark Stein has been thinking about this
quite a bit and he joins us tonight so
mark what do you what did you make this
since you're a long time long time
magazine writer you read this piece what
what did you make of the argument it
made for impeachment well first of all I
agree with your assessment of the
present diminished state of the Atlantic
Monthly and you said I was a magazine
writer I used to write for the Atlantic
a decade or so back and I'm not saying
I'm one of their Giants when you go back
through the years where they've had Mark
Twain and Lord Moulton and all kinds of
great people writing for them this thing
goes wrong right from under the the sub
headline starting the process of
impeachment will reign in a president
who is undermining American ideals and
bring the debate about his fitness for
office into Congress where it belongs
actually American ideals American values
however you want to phrase it
those transcendental values they are the
province of the people and that is the
prerogative of the people not of
bureaucrats and administrators and the
pseudo judicial process in Washington
and as for the debate about his fitness
bringing it in to him about his fitness
for office into Congress where it
belongs know that to his fitness for
office that too is in the gift of the
people and we're teaching a very
dangerous lesson here basically they're
they're not disputing that Trump was
elected according to the lawful
mechanisms of elections in the United
States what they're saying is they don't
like the result of that election and
you're teaching the people are very
dangerous lesson they are saying that
voting doesn't matter and in in essence
they're by setting in motion essentially
revolutionary conditions if you tell
people in a free society that your vote
doesn't matter I think you're absolutely
right and I think that there are leaders
on the Democratic side who sense the way
you're saying is right and there could
they could be unleashing forces they
can't control and they might be hurting
themselves what do you think would
happen politically if impeachment
oh I think it I think it would be an
absolute fiasco I mean one of the most
deplorable trends in this country in the
last few years is the attempt to
actually criminalize or position
basically this this guy's piece is
written in a kind of pseudo scholarly
pseudo judicial form but it's full of
what lawyers would call conclusory
allegations that you're not actually
allowed to make in a legal complaint he
uses you called it general badness he
accuses Trump of attacking the bedrock
of American democracy well you know
that's the that's kind of fancy writing
but what does that actually mean there
is not a there is no bedrock of American
democracy it's not down there by the
fence in El Paso and you take a pickaxe
to it you can't actually litigate that
you can revile this president you can
loathe this president right but Robert
mullahs been investigating him for two
years and has come up empty except for
Papadopoulos lying about a cocktail he
had with the Australian High
Commissioner to the United Kingdom in a
bar in London that's that's after two
years of this rubbish it was a very
dangerous cocktail though Mark Steyn put
it better than anyone I know
thank you good to see you thank you